the emperor has long loomed over the
Star Wars saga
sometimes he's manipulated events from
the shadows other times he stepped onto
the screen and shocked audiences with
his crazy powers from his days as an
apprentice to his appearance in episode
9 here's the entire emperor palpatine
story chief Palpatine the man who would
become a Sith Lord and the Galactic
Emperor was born on the planet Naboo
according to the novel Darth Plagueis
young Palpatine first discovered the
temptation of the dark side of the
forest while collecting Sith artifacts
as a young man he met Plagueis the
encounter led Palpatine to kill his
entire family and dedicate himself to
becoming Darth Plagueis Sith apprentice
as a result Plagueis gave him the name
of Darth Sidious white Plagueis before
him Sidious carefully maintained his non
sit I dent 'ti as sheep Palpatine and he
became active in politics on Naboo he
rose in rank to become a senator after
secretly arranging the assassination of
his predecessor representing that Buu in
the Galactic Senate he remained in that
position for years methodically working
to accumulate more power gaining
strength both politically and in the
dark side while Palpatine gained
popularity in the Senate Darth Sidious
formed alliances in the darker corners
of the galaxy appearing as a mysterious
cloaked figure who primarily
communicated via hologram
he contacted and manipulated groups who
were dissatisfied with the Republic such
as the Nimoy Dean's and their Trade
Federation when it was finally time to
make his bid to become Chancellor of the
Republic he encouraged the nemedians the
blockade Naboo creating a crisis that
would provide him with a political
opportunity during the same period
Palpatine took custody of a Young's
abric and had him raised in the ways of
the dark side
thus a brick became Sidious his first
set the Prentice Darth Maul since nobody
knew that he was the one behind the
trade Federation's blockade of Naboo
Palpatine was able to exploit the
incident to consolidate his political
power when Chancellor valorum failed to
take strong action to defend Naboo
Palpatine encouraged nabu's Queen
Amidala to call for a vote of no
confidence in valorum which in turn led
to a new election being the senator from
the planet that was in crisis Palpatine
was perfectly positioned to win the
election and become the new Supreme
Chancellor of the Republic taking the
top office in the galaxy was a huge step
in Palpatine's rise but it would still
take years of simultaneously
consolidating his political power as
Chancellor while also stoking the
galaxy's conflict
sistar Sidious before he would be able
to gain absolute power he would also
need a new Sith apprentice as Darth Maul
was defeated and seemingly killed by
obi-wan Kenobi as the Naboo crisis was
drawing to a close after the defeat of
Darth Maul Palpatine's new Sith
apprentice was the elderly aristocrat
Count Dooku who acted as his proxy and
leading a separatist movement of
multiple systems that were dissatisfied
with the Republic when the separatists
were found to be building a vast droid
army Chancellor Palpatine was granted
special powers to deal with the threat
as it turns out using other proxies he
had already commissioned an army of
clone troopers and his new powers
enabled him to command that army to go
to war against the separatists
not only was Palpatine's power increased
but the Republic ended a long period of
peace to become a dominant military
power in the galaxy a big step closer to
becoming an empire outwardly the
Chancellor pretended to be reluctant to
take on the burden of greater power and
lead the Republic into war but of course
it was all part of the long game he'd
been playing since the beginning three
years later Chancellor Palpatine
arranged his own capture by Count
Dooku's separatists forces he was
rescued as he knew he would be by
obi-wan Kenobi and Anakin Skywalker I
sense a trap next move spring the trap
at Palpatine's urging Anakin killed an
already defeated and literally disarmed
Dooku from then on Palpatine began
actively working to seduce Anakin to the
dark side of the force and make the
powerful young Jedi into a new Sith
apprentice Anakin was concerned for the
health of his pregnant wife Padme and
Palpatine planted the idea and Anakin's
head that becoming powerful and the dark
side was the key to ensuring that she
survived the pregnancy ultimately of
course Palpatine didn't care about Padme
at all and it was Anakin's turned to the
dark side that led to her death in his
new sith persona as Darth Vader Anakin
Skywalker would become the most powerful
ally Palpatine had ever had and a key
part of his plan to eliminate the Jedi
and rule the galaxy when the Jedi
finally realized that Palpatine was a
Sith Lord it was far too late a vicious
battle with Jedi Master Mace Windu
brought about a beer some change to
Palpatine's physical appearance while
there has been much speculation it's
unclear whether Palpatine was disfigured
by Force Lightning as he claimed or
whether he was revealing what had
already been his true appearance in any
case the evil within him came to the
surface
and his face got all gross and pasty
ironically his disfigurement enabled him
to turn the Senate against the Jedi
who'd attacked him he took the
opportunity to seize the power he'd
worked so long to bring within his grasp
and declared himself emperor of the
galaxy
although the Galactic Senate would
remain in place for years to come the
Republic had become the Empire and with
the Jedi eliminated by the clone
troopers there was nobody left to
challenge Palpatine's power almost
twenty years later
Emperor Palpatine dissolved the Galactic
Senate permanently because the
completion of the Death Star enabled him
to rule through fear commanded by one of
the Emperor's most trusted in ruthless
operatives Grand Moff Tarkin the Death
Star was a mobile space station with the
power to destroy entire planets as a
demonstration of its power Tarkin
obliterated the planet Alderaan home to
key members of the Rebel Alliance who
were working against the Empire
Leia Organa adopted princess of Alderaan
and secretly the daughter of Anakin
Skywalker was forced to watch the
destruction of her planet from the deck
of the Death Star where she was being
held prisoner at the time as these
events unfolded Emperor Palpatine
remained unseen in the background
leaving turkan and Darth Vader to do his
dirty work aboard Death Star I
recognized your foul stench when I was
brought on board charming did the last
this turned out to be particularly
fortunate for him because he was nowhere
near the Death Star when Luke Skywalker
managed to blow it off on behalf of the
Rebel Alliance Darth Vader was able to
escape the destruction but Tarkin and
the other military leaders on board all
died following the destruction of the
Death Star Emperor Palpatine and Darth
Vader both learned the identity of Luke
Skywalker and they became determined to
find him as Vader searched for Luke and
the rebels Palpatine remained in the
imperial capital of Khorasan and
communicated with Vader via hologram
Palpatine suspected that Vader wanted to
turn his son to the dark side and
overthrow Palpatine with his help
killing your master after you found your
apprentice was Sith tradition after all
then it was exactly what Palpatine had
done to his own master for his part
Palpatine hoped that either Luke would
kill his father and then replace him as
the Emperor's apprentice or that Luke
would die thus eliminating the threats
and maintaining the status quo
eventually Vader would confront Luke on
bespin but he failed to convert capture
or kill him he did however reveal
himself as Luke's father ensuring that
Luke would eventually seek out Vader by
choice which would
only put him in the path of the emperor
with construction underway on the second
Death Star Emperor Palpatine decided to
take a more active hand in the Galactic
Civil War arriving on the new Death Star
to oversee his completion himself the
Emperor carefully laid a trap for the
Rebel Alliance he knew they were
planning to attack the Death Star before
it was finished so he made sure that
when the rebels arrived the half-built
Space Station's weapons system would be
fully operational what enabled the
rebels to ultimately win the day was the
efforts of a rebel team on the surface
of the forest moon of Endor where the
new Death Star was in orbit during its
construction led by han and Leia these
rebels were eventually able to shut down
the shield generator that protected the
incomplete Death Star enabling rebel
ships to destroy it
ironically Darth Vader had allowed the
ship holding the rebel party to approach
Endor even though he sensed Luke
Skywalker's presence among them that was
the first Debaters betrayals at Endor
that led to the emperor's downfall but
it was far from the last as the emperor
had predicted Luke Skywalker soon sought
out Darth Vader on Endor the young jedi
surrendered and vader brought him before
Palpatine on the new Death Star the
Emperor could sense that the emotional
Luke was veering closer to the darkside
and he and Bader encouraged Luke to give
himself over to his emotional turmoil
Palpatine seemed ready to die if it
would cement Luke's turn to the dark
side but he was even more enthusiastic
about the possibility of Luke killing
his father and taking Vader's placed by
the Emperor's side ultimately Luke
resisted the dark side casting his
weapon away at that point Palpatine
revealed that like the armed and
operational Death Star he wasn't as weak
and helpless as he seemed the Emperor
blasted the young Skywalker with Force
Lightning from his fingertips preparing
to kill him even as the Death Star's
weapons killed Luke's allies at the last
moment however Darth Vader was unable to
stand by and watch as the man who'd
ruined his life tried to murder his son
as well and Vader grabbed Palpatine and
hurled him down a seemingly bottomless
shaft within the Death Star killing the
emperor Darth Vader died immediately
afterwards and Luke managed to escape
just as his allies finally destroyed the
second Death Star which was a decisive
victory against the Empire it's
debatable in the end whether Palpatine
died on the Death Star or not but if he
did he managed to come back pretty
quickly he never exactly says how but
cloning seems to be involved he hid
foredeck
on the planet EXA goal in the unknown
Regents he created the figure of snow
the original supreme leader of the first
order to be his puppet until it was time
for the rebirth of the Empire as the
final order he also built an entire
sitting on that hidden planet
complete with a vast fleet of
stardestroyers that would be able to
crush the resistance and once again
establish his dominance over the galaxy
when he eventually revealed himself he
recruited supreme leader kylo Ren who
had already killed Snoke and taken over
the first order Palpatine promised Ren
even greater power if Ren would fulfill
his wishes and for a time kylo seemed to
agree
somewhere along the line old pasty pal
had himself a kid and eventually his
greatest concern became his
granddaughter Rey he'd been searching
for her since she was born but she was a
grown woman before she learned about her
connection to him and journeyed 2x ago
to destroy her grandfather and end his
threat to the galaxy then she learned
that his death at her hands was part of
Palpatine's plan if she killed him in
anger she would turn to the dark side
take the spirits of him and the other
sit within her and become the new
Empress when kylo Ren having turned away
from the dark side arrived to help Rey
Palpatine drew on both of their life
forces to restore himself regaining
mobility and his trademark yellow eyes
he used his vast power to shoot the
resistance fleet out of the sky with
those fancy force fingers until a
weakened Rey managed to redirect the
Lightning back onto him basically making
Palpatine kill himself
as for Emperor Palpatine is he dead for
real now the Skywalker saga is supposed
to be over so it's nice to believe he is
but he might have just retreated to
another planet and another body waiting
for a future decade to try it all again
his ambition after all is stronger than
death check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]